blac chyna gets a paternity test to
prove
Rob Kardashian is the father of her baby
how do we get a hundred percent
probability on Sunday night's season
finale of Robin China the 28 year old
expectant mother recruited her fiance
sister Kim Kardashian to help her prove
to Rob that he's the father me and Kim
got to get some DNA on the little Kim
and China attempted to steal Rob's
toothbrush without his knowing but he
caught the girls red-handed and agreed
to take the test
outright always down just gotta end the
couple had nurses come to their home to
test the paternity and turns out
Robert Kardashian you are the father
Robin Choi's rollercoaster of a
relationship has been documented
throughout the entire first season of
their reality show but they seem to want
to stick it out and eventually expand
the family once their baby girl arrives
where would you see us evaluation our oh
man five years from now I see just way
more kids and a new house that we're
comfortable in that where that's our
house our space that we could like build
a family in and just being happy with
you Rob took to Instagram on Sunday to
share an adorable video of the two
celebrating the first year they've spent
together
sweetly writing in the caption what a
great year I'm so blessed to have met
the best mama in the world China and I
got my baby girl about to be here I
can't wait
thank you God for doing what you do